peace peace peace radio world can i bust
right here live and direct at you and um
it's december 2021 the record called
kaiju is available now on candynft.com
and you hanging out with cannot bust on
the bootleg cav podcast show y'all peace
blue lighthead podcast we got a special
guest man this guy someone who is a
legend someone who
i
remember
the trip to the warehouse record store
when i bought your first
album and
that was it 97
was it 98 well if he bought a single
would have been 97 no it was the album
so it was 98 98 yeah yeah yeah
eighth
yeah i always play my uh like i'm
driving in the car and um when my son
tries to yell at me for saying the word
[ __ ]
um i play your song
and i'm like yo there was a [ __ ] song
called get [ __ ] when i was a kid so
[ __ ] off we're from different areas
but man welcome cannabis the legend
yes sir you got a new album out too yeah
yeah kaiju right kaiju
kaiju so um
ask me
what you want to know about yeah what is
what is the what's what's what's what
tell us about the title well first of
all start there yeah pretty much kaiju
was um
so that that's the that's the word or
the term that was going to
uh pretty much um
you know the umbrella for all those like
those godzilla movies those big monster
movies you know um
you know japanese folklore and uh you
know before all the animations japanese
you had
we grew up on it i mean i i don't know
what year you were born i was born in 87
no i was yeah i was born in 87. you were
old enough definitely like on a saturday
you know get up and see like all of
these you know the stuff going on on a
saturday with after the cartoon of
course they go through the
you know the mystery science theater and
all of these so kaiju is the name that
that embodies all of those types of
films
um
so it means big it means like monster
prius some monster [ __ ] yeah well yeah
but sometimes the monsters were good
guys though
so so i don't know if they were monsters
you know all the way sometimes they were
good guys just sometimes you need a
really big fix for a big problem right
100 right so kaiju i'm a good monster
i feel like you've been extremely like
you know you did also the the horseman
project finally we got that right shout
out to the horsemen team that's right
it's been a long time coming i just i i
feel like you you you come in and out of
hip-hop
like we won't hear from you and then
we'll be like oh [ __ ] there's there's a
horseman album or there's a new cannabis
album or like
i
you know you're
what i like to call i always say that
there's a few jedi's in the rap game and
i think you are one of the jedis when it
comes to just
your abilities when it comes to this rap
[ __ ] like
how passionate are you about
making music still
so
that's a big accomplishment i really
appreciate you even saying there's a big
compliment man i'm pretty much
huge compliment i was a star wars fan
growing up you know you know there's a
few there's there's a handful of jedi's
in the game you're one of them man there
is and um
but to be one of them
it's a lot it's a lot of pressure to
even take on that title right so i can't
really i can't take credit for it i
can't take on that title but to even be
considered and you know have my name in
the hat it's a big deal to me and that's
the way i kind of
kind of um
run through it now in my mind and also
in practice
where uh
hip hop you know the real moguls out
there the ones who make all the
decisions you know the taste makers the
king makers um
those are i guess the real jedi's man
because they were able to maneuver
through
a lot of the bear traps a lot of the
you know a lot of the the things that
were set up to like derail artists who
had certain certain elements to them
that maybe you know was wasn't uh
you know
you know was wasn't mainstream ready
right you know certain little facets of
people in their music that you know
the system didn't really want to i mean
if we take it back to the days of like
nwa right right
the title is an acronym why mm-hmm
because at that time
no one was able to handle what the name
really meant what it actually meant yeah
you know what i mean and then you know i
mean look at there's that album from nas
right there which originally wasn't
going to be called n okay right yeah
you know the hard r you know
so so you and i
we we were participating in the culture
at a time when
we couldn't even say the things that
people say now with we kind of took all
the heat
from making it possible to say whatever
the hell you want right and express
yourself and um
so you know like i said the moguls are
probably the real jedi
we're we're like me myself the moguls
can't craft a 32
bar verse like you can
you know
i just mean in terms of like your
abilities you know like when we think of
like
nba 2k and we look at someone's rankings
like your rapping ability is like a 99
you know what it's not look i really do
appreciate you and for saying that and i
appreciate that and i appreciate
you know the fans the brotherhood people
that you know say it out loud yeah think
it out loud but like i said the moguls
in my mind the moguls
the like the people who
are on the phone
24 hours a day like i was just getting
an example of it like a jedi to me that
would be like m80 and maybe it's over
here yeah because without without people
like that
your record doesn't see the light of day
you see what i'm trying to say yeah
because you know some if if we if we if
we use your
you know
your perspective on it then
these jedi's man these jedi's can't even
get their record played these jedi's
can't get an interview right now these
jedis can't make you get what i'm trying
to say what you're saying that's that's
why that's why we you know that's why i
just i fall back
you know stay in my lane now um i enjoy
it
you know what i mean life is not all rap
no matter what people think you know
what i mean and just spread it out and
try to
you know try to try to try to get the
best of what's what's left for us you
know we're we're all we're all like
nearing half a century now yeah
everybody for my ever well yeah in half
a century so yeah you know you know you
just said life isn't all wrap and i feel
like you were somebody who embraced that
concept
relatively early on in your career it
was all right for me
but i mean for somebody who
was so dedicated to being right to your
craft right right like i feel like
you know
you know i feel like you know when you
enlisted to join you know the armed
services like
sometimes we get so wrapped up in
perception
you know the hip hip hop is all about
perception right like absolutely when we
like
i had a you know i'm real cool with
little brother okay so uh rapper baby
shut up rapper big poo and and fonte
a couple of other jedi's right but big
poo you know openly talked about how he
was driving uber you know just for some
money on this right that's right that's
right and like to me it was like yeah
that's that's okay because this is not
um
we're all real real real human beings
absolutely and and sometimes we get so
wrapped up in like perception because
that's really what the hip-hop game is
it's like it's kind of like it's like
it's like a weird like pure sport and i
feel like you kind of exist in your own
world where you can come in
drop an album yeah and then we might not
hear from you for like another year you
know what i mean like why or how it's
like that that's a little bit above my
pay grade to even try to quantify how it
got like that but i feel like
at all times
i feel like at all times
all of the artists that come from our
era
were multitasking i mean you know a lot
of us come from single-parented homes
you know what i mean like we we were all
doing things that
we were able to
multitask and you know helping mama pay
the bills or helping grandma you know
get this together and you know helping
grandpa going down we all from my error
we came from that right and i'm talking
about the things that are favorable and
the things that are not so favorable
right he did whatever it took to you
know make our make our family proud or
you know bring home the bacon right and
so
you know
i think that during our era we were all
able to jump rope in a lot of different
ways also you probably had to too right
because
we did the deals back then were a lot
more predatory as well yeah but i mean
when look even when time to go to like
sam ash or jr music world or you know uh
you know you know the guitar center
right right
remember we were the ones that the ikai
the machines these drum machines we were
the ones that would take this equipment
and show them what it could really do
right they didn't have anybody else who
could even could even work these
machines out the way that we could but
you still had to buy it man you still
had to put plastic on the smiley had to
come in here and either co-sign it or
you working one two three jobs to get
the cash or you know a homie that is
already getting it like that he'll spot
you the bread to go get the equipment to
go make the samples to go make the demos
to go get you know go make the deal you
see what i'm trying to say there were
always multiple steps that had to be
taken to get on so paying dues was not a
short it wasn't a short-term thing man
like you you kind of were in it before
you knew
what what what it was about the the what
you was trying to get to you were
looking at it through a telescope when
you got to it you realize that that road
is a little bit more arduous than you
thought it was and
so
like i said man i just feel like we all
were doing more at that time to get on
we were all more we had more solid
footing
when we got there but as we grew
so did the majors so did the those that
you know paid our checks those the
buildings that we kept the lights on and
they also grew and i guess at some time
they started you know they had to cut
weight right they had to when when it
was time for them to get into a
championship fight they had to cut
weight and so when they cut weight they
would they would always cut what
maybe wasn't keeping the lights on as
long right and obviously that's going to
always gravitate back towards branding
right and the people who were branding
was with the corporate guys you know the
clothing manufacturers and stuff like
that
and funny enough because here we are
again right back into this you know a
lot of new things are coming out they
need people to brand it but they don't
need rap anymore now all they need is
social media
we were hip-hop we were the world's
first social media yeah rap was yeah for
sure you guys were at the first
influencers you were the first man
because if you think about it nowadays
you just find someone who's got you know
some kid who's got
15 million followers on tick tock that
doesn't really have a talent but they
can pop your [ __ ] off that's right back
then you needed rayquan to wear tommy
he'll figure it out you know what i mean
right you needed jay-z to pop your
christmas oh you know what i mean that's
right now you just finished oakley code
yeah
yeah it's crazy uh you know it's crazy
this because i i feel like you
when we we you know
and m80 would know this we always hear
of of the lyrical spiritual miracle
rappers you've heard that term right
i feel like you are the quintessential
when we think of the lyrical spirit i
feel like i when when people say that i
think of cannabis right
right you have so many intricate ryan
patters [ __ ] the vocabulary is insane
you're [ __ ] i feel like sometimes
i'll be hearing you rapping it's like
math problems and all kinds of
algorithmic [ __ ] going on like
i feel like you you you are that guy
like what do you like explain to me your
writing process so in the beginning it's
funny you say that because
in the beginning we were all lyrical
miracle guys right you know what i'm
saying but then
because that's what we'd get on is we
just say look because you know he's
saying lyrical so you look at the next
word around with lyrical i'm saying
lyrical miracles spiritual individuals
and all that we were all that in the
beginning all of us were right and then
and then it got to the point where
some artists came out and they were more
you know to the to that the bling i'm
not i'm not singling out you know shout
out to cash money but i'm not singling
them out the bling bling the bling phase
because they started to bring error
right yeah so when the bling era came
and so much bread was being made from it
that you know
everybody started getting bread on that
side of things and then the lyrical
miracle dudes was just the backpackers
and the lyrical miracle dudes were broke
and they hadn't so then you found
dudes that were lyrical miracles you
know
laughing at other lyrical miracles wait
a minute there was a woman
yeah yeah and then and then and then and
then and then so one of my homies does
he doesn't say the lyrical miracle he's
with the fly guy with the tie-dye with
my my tie yeah so that's what that's
what it became and
you know it's kind of crazy when
you got your own you know dudes cut from
the same cloth you know rhyme ability
wise laughing at the lyrical miracles so
then because
you know the machine helped them get the
bread
you can't get the bread and then certain
things started happening so
yeah man i mean
you know i was happy to graduate out of
the lyrical miracle
phase because it was a phase we all go
through
then i got into the poetry and i did
that probably circle right
what i say right for whom to be told oh
seven that's when it got to where
the rhymes that were coming out of my
mouth
no one could shadow them they would you
didn't know what i was going to say next
because
you know lyrical wasn't going to rhyme
with miracle
i was going to make lyrical rhyme with
you know what i molybdenum
that's so
yeah but that that lyrical miracle error
was was fun i just think like i think
like you know i guess since since uh
you know i think of your era it was like
guys like yourself like like razz like
obviously a guy who's a partner in the
horseman shout out to rashford
nature of the thread is [ __ ] amazing
um
but then i think even after that like i
think of like at least on the forefront
commercially wise like
i think lupe is one of those guys who's
just like a [ __ ] alien you know yeah
but they didn't let us have our lane
though like they we had a lane and no
one
set up an hov lane for us
there was no hov lane for us we were we
would still
getting in and out of lanes and really
had no place there was no home
for us you know
yeah i know for sure and you know what's
crazy is like
we think back like what you just said
there was lyrical guys calling out lyric
like there was a divide
and i think back to how crazy it was
when kanye west put lip quality
uh
or i'm sorry when uh jay-z put tyler
quality in that when he said
i'd probably be lyrically taller quality
and i'm like yo to think that there was
a point in time where we thought that
jay-z and talib were so far apart right
when they aren't at all right
and like
you know it it
or when most deaf and freeway
were put on that record of two was it
two words right at the end of college
dropout by kanye west it was so weird
because it felt like
kanye brought two worlds together most
deaf and freeway when in gen like
they're they're the same [ __ ] but that's
where things are so different now
because now there's like real
serious divides in hip-hop as far as
like you know back then it was like hey
just somebody happen to have a
commercial record deal and maybe have a
club record
but at the same time
you know raucous records felt so far
away from rockefeller right but they
weren't really were they really like no
of course not like and even then like
you mentioned cash money little wayne's
one of the greatest rappers of all time
absolutely you know what i mean
when you heard the rockers rockers
records though like but the owner of
that at the time
it's like it's like a super mogul
you know and but no one knew that though
right
no one knew that so it just felt like
there was this huge divide between like
the backpack [ __ ] the you know what we
what we would consider the quote-unquote
real hip-hop right and the commercial
[ __ ] which was also real hip-hop
now i feel like there is a serious like
you know at least maybe not as much
anymore as there was like a few years
ago when the soundcloud [ __ ] really went
crazy and little pump was [ __ ] huge
and i was really like
okay i'm old right yeah yeah i feel you
you know but i do think it's dope that
now
no matter what
the last 10 to 12 years the top four
guys are all
amazing drake j cole
kendrick lamar yeah these guys are all
absolutely right yeah these guys are all
like at the they're the forefront of
hip-hop right and they're all extremely
high-level high-caliber
rappers yeah you tell them keeping the
lights on as well right yeah they keep
the lights on at every label that
they're at but they also are incredibly
tanned so i think it just says that like
no matter what like there might be eras
where people come and go but the the
cream is always gonna rise to the top
and be the constant you know what i mean
right who are you a fan of like who do
you listen to that's you know
maybe not from your era that's a little
bit newer that like you really respect
as far as on the mic
i mean
you know gotta tell you man um
it just it just ranges man it depends on
um
who like maybe might come nieces and
nephews to come over the house they're
playing stuff
you know
they want to listen to that you know i
might have to sit and lend an ear to it
because i'm you know watching over them
for a little bit right
and um you hear the music and
irregardless of what they're saying like
the delivery now is a lot tighter from
these little youngins than it was when
we were coming up oh yeah man
yeah the melodic [ __ ] is amazing like
people are making great records right
now they're making good records but also
you know
and content-wise i want to make the
distinction like they don't have enough
experience to make the porgy that that
the error enough life enough life
experiences yeah there's no way in a way
for them to put that kind of poetry
together um they'll get there but
insofar as the delivery
you know
it it amazes me even how they're able to
do that and some of them don't have any
classical musical training like they
don't they don't even know
people talk about bars and don't really
even know where the bar is
right so that's always going to be
something that you got to look at
you know razor brow or two to know that
i guess they're just born with it now
like instinctually
they come out the womb and they have a
metronome that they can follow and they
can double time just on cue and they can
double time they can you know you can
switch up to time signatures like what
they do now is amazing um
but like i said
the older generation one want to maybe
look you know if they were looking for
anything from the newer generation the
latest generosity we've been looking for
you know certain things content-wise
but you know they can't provide that yet
but they'll get there and then when they
get there the next graduating class will
be coming in and they'll be speaking
about something they'll probably be
delivering
you know through some kind of ai
metaverse you know i'm saying people
rhyming with the goggles on for sure i
mean and once you got that and you got
backgrounds going on and you got now
you know who can compete with that right
because visually you're giving
whatever consumers at that time is going
to be looking you're giving them
something that you know the era that
we're looking at now that's maybe two
behind us
they wouldn't even be able to compete
with them so this is this is a cyclical
cycle this is you know cyclical it's
gonna continue on and on
i really i look at it as like an
observer man from the outside man i just
i i i just break out the popcorn bro i'm
saying when you're listening to music
you still listening to a lot of hip-hop
not really not really man you know what
i'm saying i i throw
to tell you i know it sounds crazy man
but you know if i go on you know if i'm
on the xfm i'm i'm just listening to
like uh
you know music that has no words you
know what i mean like i might sit there
and just listen to norah and pure you
know what i mean right because riding
around it makes me feel rich you know
from listening to norman pure it makes
me feel rich if i'm listening to you
know this this emcee or this rap kid on
here talking about i don't feel rich i
feel like damn i feel broke as [ __ ] you
know just gotta just that in the third i
don't got that you know what i mean i'd
rather just listen to something that you
know just a little bit more you know
soundscape
you know heavy bass uh tempo going crazy
you know what i mean something that you
can just relax your mind to because you
really sit down and listen to these guys
when you feel like you're missing out on
all the good things in life raps
shouldn't really be like that man right
right right you shouldn't have to listen
to rap and feel like you're missing out
on life you should be able to listen to
rap and feel like
you know like like okay this is where i
want to be but rap now makes you feel
like you're not where you want to be and
you made a mistake and i need to do what
you do it's been like that for a while i
mean you mentioned the bling bling here
i think it really started pretty pretty
heavily you know with cash money because
it was like yo birdman's rapping about
having a [ __ ]
a car with a driver's seat in the middle
it's yeah
yeah but look you can't put it all on
youtube no i'm just saying it started
then and some people probably listen
like i love that [ __ ] let me give you
the inside i'm gonna give you an insight
to it it really it really didn't start
with those guys man like those guys were
just answering a call it started with
our magazines right mm-hmm so so you had
these magazines like
you know the magazines the swords
yeah other magazines others right all of
them right right
there was a time when those magazines
were very thin
because there were no ads in them
then they all got loaded up and once
they got lower they got thicker not just
in the back also in the middle with the
peel outs right right once they went
there
anybody could go look it up and see
that's when the article started to go
from being favorable or agreeable like
like oh yeah we got such-and-such most
you know most loved or you know someone
who's known for such-and-such like all
accolades and praise right to
to
oh yeah the east coast west coast war
started because such and such they said
and then that was in bold lettering and
then the division started right that's
when the division started the vision
started when
magazines started to put in bold writing
disagreements that people had that had
nothing to do with the album outright
but they grabbed the narrative they were
grabbing narratives
poisonous yeah poisonous to us and they
fed it back to us
and so you know you know what happens
when you feed
bovine cowboy vine bones right right
what happens breaks down it degenerates
right it turns into like you know
ms or
yeah i think i think obviously cow
disease right that's what they did to us
they fed us our own dead
right i mean i think when when these
magazines realize that's what sold
because think about it back then you
couldn't go on social media and address
someone directly or in real time right
right it was like i gotta wait to see
what they say in the next vibe or
i you know it was so much he said she
said because there was no
direct to consumer way to communicate
with fans well yeah but i mean you got
to take responsibility you know
everybody's got to be accountable right
like if
you know there were other magazines you
know skiing
biking you know the stuff that right
william randolph hearst did you know
everything was photo photography skiing
biking boating
all the ings right
he just got them all and he added ing to
every hobby every recreational pastime
and it sold you go look in those
magazines they were dividing their own
culture right you didn't even see people
dividing
cell craft with
you know
diesel engines first gas you know people
make comparisons but they didn't make it
to where like you know don't buy this
you know
mirror but but like right
right it's only in rap and so that's
that tells you that there was an agenda
involved you know but what confuses me
always is that
rap just kind of keeps going down the
same
circle
uh that those same bear traps pitfalls
it just they just break out a same you
know a recurring pitfall every five or
ten years and people fall into it for
example
i don't understand how the owners of
these magazines didn't see
10 years ahead in the future which ain't
even long
can't you see that by putting these
things by grabbing the narrative and
making it negative in your magazine
right can't you see that all that's
gonna do is push your magazine out the
window eventually to where
you're not going to have the staff
you know you eventually you're going to
kill your own culture
through the magazine right you're going
to kill your magazine
the the the
the uh the platforms are gonna change
you're gonna go online now you don't
have a staff anymore right and i can say
this because i was i lived it like you
know when you had promotional marketing
man there was a time
you're from a relatively same era there
was a time when
craft services used to get money from
coming to our videos coming to the you
know to the um the meet and greets just
parking the truck outside the food truck
outside the promotions the market and
promotions guys used to get buku bucks
man they used to go yeah they have to go
to the record stores and make sure you
had your your setup and your posters in
the record stores and yeah the the you
know somebody making some clothes you
know just got some some garms and stuff
like that everyone was getting paid
everybody was getting bread you know
that's what i'm saying and it was coming
out of your budget it was up
now i'm talking about the cell phone
i'm telling the self man i'm not i'm not
talking about labels paying people i'm
talking about people making the work
right that you was able to get it all
back
through being busy every day right doing
what you loved
that was the time we were still doing
what we loved but then like i said
things just started to get
strained and it's like they put us
through some kind of a funnel and what
came out the other end was
all right well now you just upload your
music and we don't need anybody to
promote you can pay for it but that just
means we're just going to digitally send
a signal and ping the website and get
avatars and get bots
right right so
you know and it's it's it's really
alarming man you just look and you see
how much power does the average
rapper have man
not much
and that's crazy to me
yo you mentioned the metaverse a bit
earlier but i know that you uh you you
you're in nfc space a bit yeah yeah the
metaverse yeah i'm listening but i'm
just curious like what um you've always
kind of been ahead of the curve
when it comes to the online [ __ ] or just
certain [ __ ] like um total courage man
talk about the nft [ __ ] man because
obviously i think a lot of artists are
still trying to figure out the space
it's new right
we
starting to kind of understand what it
is but at the same time right are very
disconnected to what it really is right
so so you you're in the space um
how are you feeling about like kind of
just that whole side of the game okay so
a lot a lot of it you know i'm only
qualified to speak on a fraction of what
what an nft can do or where it's going
right mainly because um
a lot of the
you know you got to be a coder man like
you really have to you know to really
know what you're doing man like it's
like because i've worked with some of
those guys and and i mean they're like
brainiacs man you know and most of them
from what i see they're like our age
they're not little young as me because
they had to go and invest the time
mm-hmm to learn these programs and they
have to know how to code right right
right right now as you as you talk about
like if you want to go build a website
you got to go get somebody from india to
do it
right
when i remember when i was building
spitballs.com this is a long time ago
this is 2010. and um you know my team
and i you know we're handling building
spitballs.com and i got to tell you man
like there were only two coders
in the country one was in miami and was
in colorado they could have built the
site so we had to outsource to india
no problem with that it's just that
india has different holidays from us so
we were trying to get things done it was
like oh man they're on holiday gotta hit
him back this time you know or ramadan
look can't do cipher right so that's
kind of crazy considering it and it's
been like that for a long time and so
nfts
wow there's a lot to it and there's a
lot that can happen because of it
i think rap is going to miss the boat
with it again man because once again you
know they're not our own people
are not
they're not paying attention to the ones
who stand to
gain and lose the most if we don't get
something like that for ourselves
they're not listening to them they want
to go run
to just to cope the corporate masters
right
that that you know really kind of don't
care one way or another if you make
something that your grandchildren are
going to be able to tap into to
you know go to school you know get
higher education right
and
that's not my ask the grind man i'm just
saying that
to even sit up here and talk about nft
stuff
i mean i was talking about cannabis.com
when nobody gave a [ __ ] right you know
me to talk about it now
i mean people are people i mean you you
i saw you just had some nft
i mean how many i tell you just put up
an nft right i don't have any nfts i
swear if you go online and you look for
gamers entities you don't have any kind
of entities but the whole thing is that
you know i'm i'm orbiting the technology
and i'm orbiting the nft world because
there are things that are works of art
that i would like to you know i would
like to either ascertain right or you
know have investors you know angel
investors come in
and ascertain right um because okay so
this this board ape you know nft which
is poor yacht club thing right now you
look at that right now
if you look at it
it's colorful
it it does draw on you a little bit when
you look at it right to at least for you
to scroll look at the next one right and
you think maybe that like
you know maybe there's a maybe there's
like a
a hip
you know someone that has like hip-hop
roots behind it
and it's probably not probably not and
and that's kind of like crazy so we're
so where are the hip-hop guys that
because the prices of those things are
insane right so so so
how
how would we ever be able to participate
in something like that when it's
happening right now
and none of us are in that that space so
it's almost like is it too late
or like do you think it's too late for
people to get into that too late it's
too late because of the division that
you talked about earlier because it's
like you know no one's gonna pull
together enough to go do that everyone
else i mean now that we're speaking
about that let me let me let me pretty
much
so i don't have all the answers for that
but i do have a place that has the
answers for it right that i know of that
that i've alright so
you know this is what i i just throw
this out yo okay rippers investors hood
philanthropy hood philanthrop
philanthropists
grandpas with bitcoins grandmas with
[ __ ] coins look in the eye pictorial app
available on google play at victoria.com
secure your future with customized
epictorio iovs that's internet of value
tools i'm talking cannabis coins
jurassic 5 j5 coins hieroglyphics hydro
coins
there's five coins yeah and can't right
right every coin you can cross chain
anything think bank pictorial finance
there's no one with coins on exchanges
they're going to be on coinbase and the
nasdaq index special rewards coins with
membership powers at victoria's smart
wallets for smart people with
smartphones make smart money from smart
contracts jim cole classes begin january
2022
available on i pictorial wallet all of
this will be available on january 1st
2022. now this is a small company right
with long reach right i just said that
on there right
i'd be surprised to see how many people
go there and try to take advantage of or
look into what's there for them right
now you know x amount of days later
after this broadcast i find out right
and most likely like the way that i see
it is because i said it no one cares
right but this company they're building
on their own without me saying that
right so they're probably going to grab
onto something else out there that's
going to win and then you know we're
going to be looking at the people who we
told about like but we told you though
right and they're gonna run off with
somebody else that's gonna you know
distribute their
their musics
put their take their namesake you know
you know get their their crypto world
together you know
their while it's like you know get all
that stuff that's very important and i
know why but i can't say it why because
it doesn't matter unless they go look it
look into an eye pictorial the epitoria
app right
but
one day very soon they're gonna wake up
and they're going to be in that world
already you can't buy anything
in that world you're not going to be
able to
uh earn it you're not going to be able
to get any air drops you're not going to
be getting it you're just going to wake
up you're just going to owe it and
you're going to have to go to work until
you get it and that's in the same way we
have to do that for the u.s dollars
right you got to earn the us dollar so
one day you're not gonna be able to
purchase
into that world that's right you're
gonna have to work into that world
that's right which is which is a crazy i
mean
that's a crazy thought but eventually
for us though i think that us we're
going to still be able to do what we do
and do what we're what we're good at
doing right it's the new generation man
we're talking about our kids here
tomorrow grandchildren yeah
grandchildren this is what we're really
talking about we're talking about that
kind of stuff that's what we're really
talking about because we're able to
we're able to get it in so many
different ways you're right you're right
right this is probably maybe 50 100
years away yeah you know um i wanted to
talk to you so i know i'm sure you saw
uh
was it ll got into the rock and roll
hall of fame that's right he got
inducted right he got inducted and he
shot him he shouted you out just about a
month now right yeah it's about a month
ago and he shouted you out in the speech
which i thought was dope because in my
opinion top three
battles as a kid
i remember obviously second round
knockout
and i remember going and buying dmx's
it's dark and hell is hot the bonus disc
version because the second there was a
there was a def jam version of that
album that had a
bonus disc in it that had the the ripper
strikes back on it right right yeah
that's right and um i just remember
knowing both of those records by heart
and just thinking like damn like i like
just it was such a just an epic time uh
epic battle but i always felt like there
was always respect and i thought it was
just so dope to see all these years
later ll just show you some love you
know i mean it's a shame that we didn't
wwf it right
and what i mean by that is like
like why couldn't
there have been some wise elder right
to come out and just say all right
listen man
you guys kissing makeup right now right
but on the screen yeah yeah yeah do that
and let's all really just get rich and
let's let's go ahead and create to do
this take this template and do it every
time rap artists get into beef instead
for us there was no wwf
they put everybody in a situation like
this is real
you can't sleep tonight because you got
dissed you know what i'm saying you
can't show your face because you got
dissed right you're under pressure
because you got dissed
you you know what i mean you're not
you're not the artist that we all
thought you were because you got dissed
like hip-hop kind of did a number on the
both of us i think and every artist
thereafter and before they got into you
know disagreements with each other
there was no at no time
during on my watch was i able to witness
someone that was wise coming into the
fray
right and saying
you know what there's a way to wwf this
before everyone gets paid that's right
that's right we take our rapper hats off
at the end of the night never happened
yeah never happened so that's how i look
at the whole thing i don't
everything y'all talking about what
y'all saying to me man it's chinese
because what what what everybody else is
talking about is something that still we
spent what five minutes talking about
this so far it makes no money right
nobody gets anything from it
but on the wwf side of things
they eat bro of course so i use
wrestling and i'm not slow yeah and i'm
not slow so i kind of feel i kind of
feel i feel insulted i feel like
i got stuck with the dummies
you know what i mean i got put into the
genre music
guy had to get to do that with the
dummies you know what i mean i should
have been on another side where it's
like you know somebody the wise man
comes down off the off the mountain he's
got the plan and he says i like what you
guys just did you know what
let's go get some money with it instead
on this side of things
almost like a paul heyman that's right
let's do it but on this side of thing
with rap
the guy comes off the top of the
mountain and says man
you won't believe what he said to me
about you up there man if i was you i go
up to you see what i'm trying to say i
hear what you're saying and then they
just wipe us out we wipe ourselves out
and i and i'm i'm confused as to how
nobody has can see it yet yeah i mean
and if and hey look there might be
situations that we just aren't privy to
where that might have happened you know
i don't know but i just don't think that
we'd ever be exposed i love you bro but
that's [ __ ] no i don't know i don't
know i mean the way word of mouth goes
on and rap no you're right it's a bunch
of gossiping bro yeah man so when you
but when you when you heard him shout
you out like i mean obviously that was
the phone went crazy yeah the texts were
crazy you know um
[Music]
you know i was
i didn't remember what i was doing at
the time oh i was writing i was writing
for kaiju wow i was writing i was
writing i was i was vocaling right i was
vocaling and i put the phone on airplane
mode so when i took it off it was like
thing went crazy yeah and then i was
like oh man oh just no not stupid i'm
thinking it's something stupid right i
think he got up there and said yo man i
want to see cannabis in the pine box you
understand what i'm saying i'm just
telling you right what i thought when i
looked at it and then when i heard it
was the opposite
you know it did feel good
you know now while now wow now while of
course
you know what if i was like stuck
somewhere in south africa
right and i couldn't get back to the
states or right what if i'd been human
trafficked somewhere right
think about this right what if i was
somewhere else
unable to communicate back right but i
heard about that
how you supposed to feel
you're not supposed to feel like this
shout out
is any kind of guiding light from the
creator like you know just hang in there
kid you're at it right right right then
this is not the way that rap i feel in
the beginning
this is not the way that it was meant
to
uh develop
i don't feel that way because
every other
the word team
the word genre the word group
the word uh
i mean just any synonym to you know like
like a
group right right people
right any other synonym is going to you
look up the examples or you look up
something that's comparable you're going
to see that
we don't leave nobody behind
you know what i mean all right you know
what
we keep our scuffles inside the family
you know what i mean everybody oh that's
got to be paid so forth and so on but
you know what we don't leave nobody
behind man
rap
bro
i'm i'm i'm good man i'm good because
you know what i mean i got other things
doing and working right right but for
those who don't
you gotta you gotta guest list so long
and rap of people that could come up
here and talk about being left behind
yeah i'm telling you bro i mean no 100
it's not something right with that
picture man i agree i mean i'm not here
to fix it either but nobody but you're
right you're right so so don't so i
don't want anybody to come talk to me
like i'm slow about
a shout out or something like that i'm
not miserable about it i'm saying it
don't don't even waste my time man you
know what i mean about something that
it doesn't mean anything you understand
i get it wait hold on time to stop the
interview because we got to talk about
our good folks at odd socks man listen
if you go to
oddssoxofficial.com that's odd sox
soxofficial.com use the keyword keyword
it's a [ __ ] promo code use the
[ __ ] promo code bootleg kev all right
at checkout you'll save 20 off they got
i mean look at these spongebob joints
man the ninja turtle boys you know what
i'm saying how about the naruto guys
and then they got the new odd socks
basics that are just like
they're just so fly man the tie-dye
joints they just listen man
whatever you need they got it how about
some half-baked boys you know what i'm
saying listen
the most comfortable socks the most
affordable socks the best socks in the
world odd socks so go to
oddssocksofficial.com
use that keyword it's not a keyword it's
a [ __ ] promo code
[ __ ]
bootleg cab at checkout save 20 off man
shout out to our family at odd socks if
you support us go support them
another thing i wanted to talk to you
about
folklore it's not folklore because it's
on youtube you
mike geronimo
dmx
pun
most dev you're right that's correct
john forte i remember that
vaguely anyway
it's like uh one of the more historical
just ciphers that was ever captured from
that era
yeah
like you know you know torrey
torres should have taurasia the guy gave
us like he did somebody did tell us to
do sign off she's tori she gave us like
a percentage on that
yeah tori was the guy he ended up you
know journalism yeah the journalist yeah
he been yeah i mean i remember seeing
his face on cnn one day like yo that
dude
yo it's like the beef dvd right i
remember the beef so qd3 shout out to
qd3 yeah that's quincy john's son right
that's right yeah that's right but i
mean it's like yo percentage on that
would have been nice you know yeah the
fact that he made so much money on three
three or four of those dvds and no one
saw anything off of it listen to me
those beef dvds are moving into the moon
without playing i got three of them i
got them at my house stop playing so
this that that's all i'm saying man like
when it just came it seemed like when it
came to rap made it's like winner takes
all
you know and um i mean look the
entertainment industry in general is
very predatory right yeah but hold on
though man
anywhere else in the entertainment
industry man there are
ancillary
you know
uh like what drops on the head drips on
the shoulder so there are things that
that drop off the tree man it's like
it's like okay that fruit is ripe or
it's over ripe but it's still sustenance
but in rap
listen man our
our va list you know of injured and
wounded and you know otherwise
is
it's it's
it's unbearable
yes that's true it's unbearable and um
i can't do anything about it i don't
have the resources to do anything about
it every time i try to go get the
resources to do something about it i was
blocked one way or another right the
narrative was stolen taken from me and
the narrative changed into something
that was like had something to do with
beef or drama right
but
i'm only speaking on it now
to just
kind of just say hey just build a little
bit of awareness about it and sort of
like kind of like you know put my hat
cast no i think that there's been a
bunch of attempts of like right like
what is like the retirement plan for
hip-hop or the ins or or just there's so
many right like why are there more
safety nets for artists you know like at
the end of the day like if a major label
they chew you up and spit you out if
you're not worthy so i've heard that on
clubhouse there's been talks about um
different things like uh
man i i don't want to say the wrong name
of the double og and rap music
that is pushing it i don't want to say
the wrong name so i know that it's
somebody's jay prince i think is behind
that's not the name
i guess i know there's a few there yeah
there's a few but but um
but
something about having like
sit before the supreme court sign the
petition sit before the supreme court
and try to get uh like uh uh uh benefits
um retirement packages medical things
like that for artists right now
great idea superb idea but you know what
though
it's too late and the reason i say that
is because
how can you
go before like the american people or
any type of global audience right when
you're nearing you know like i said our
era is half a century in right
and then those that came a little bit
ten years before us they're 60
60 years in or better then you got those
that are 70 and nearing 80.
how are you going to sit in front of you
know a
three generations later you're sitting
in front of them and you're you're
asking them for more money when we
traveled the globe we made the money
you see what i'm trying to say it's a
little bit it's a little bit lopsided
right right these things should have
kind of been set up before so now you
know little things we were talking about
earlier now you might want to try to you
know try to steer the youngins in a
certain direction to secure their own
futures
um
and then you kind of get blocked with
that too so it's kind of like we'll
railroad it either way you know what i
mean because there are things now that
they could do to secure their future so
you could rather literacy right it's
like i feel like i feel like
unfortunately like like we're talking
about retirement plans and stuff like
any artist
they're just a little bit more
and and we're talking about 18 19 year
old kids you know what i mean just
trying to
improve their life conditions absolutely
so they're just going to sign but at the
same time it's like man like we just got
to do a better job and i think we are
part of the first generation that's
probably
taking financial literacy a little bit
more serious of course um of course but
you know a lot of that stuff like
unfortunately like you said it's
probably never going to happen so it's
really up to the it's up to the artist
you gotta you gotta take care of your
[ __ ]
because it because all that we could do
accumulatively is set up some type of
safety net for those that
um
they're not done their careers are not
over with music right but the safety
net's there to kind of get them back on
track if they do want to you know get
back into it right right there should be
some kind of a some kind of a safety net
from somewhere but that really doesn't
exist i don't think it
it will exist i don't think so so it's
up to the individuals
yes just to be more literate so
basically we're asking we're asking
we're asking youngest who came and you
know dedicated they committed everything
you know to hip-hop you know they took
on the risk they took on i mean
everything they went into these dark
rooms you know they went in there with
these mvgs on they did their best they
did you know they they did everything
that you know most people would be
scared to do
terrified petrified to do these little
young as we're here and did this and
we're asking them to go in there and do
all of this and not have any there's
nothing on the other side for them you
know what i mean and that's kind of
i yo man i just
yo man i get so like defeated even
thinking about it that's real yeah i
mean look it's like it's like any any if
anybody ever told you like hey look this
is your career but there's no
you know when you sign up to be a doctor
or a lawyer or anything you know that
there's
a safety net yeah you know what i mean
there might be benefits or whatever it
is
take me back to that night from that
cypher right
big pun is one of my favorite ever i
mean most i mean i mean this is just
this is a crazy night in hip-hop dmx is
there i mean you're there like what what
do you remember about that night in
those circumstances from that night i
remembered it in that room
as
as
as
tense as it was because of what we all
were trying to do in our own lives we
all wanted to come out make our impacts
um
you know
plant our flags in the ground
right
and
firmly make an impact in hip-hop
across the world that's what we wanted
to do
uh we were all american artists right um
you know you know of course coming from
different lineages right and then and
everyone on the cusp of being the next
big thing right right right and then and
then ethnically it was it was really
spread out all throughout you know it
was spread it was spread out as a spread
out round table right
but
um
in spite of how intense it was what i
what i distinctly remember was
as much as each one of us
was willing to go hard
with them rhymes and other things to to
make that statement
there was still
complete love in that room
and you can look at it and tell like
like there was love for each other
respect
for each you know that's what you need
you didn't see anything jump off in
there that was like
unbecoming of you know artists that are
kind of like in their freshman role
trying to get it popping like we we
showed love to each other and that and
we did there was no security there
we didn't need any actually there was no
hype man there there was no there was no
squads nobody had a whole squad standing
outside the door like so
that much i remember i remember that
there was love in that room and the love
i think was probably uh
was probably resonant because of
the the lyrical miracle ability right
everybody we all had that ability here
so everybody respected one another's
pain game and we we all knew
consciously and subconsciously that we
were kind of like all up against the
same machine we weren't up against each
other we were up against the same
machine because we were trying to get
something from the machine in order to
go feed our little huskies and our
munchkins
and you know and branch out
and so uh that's what i remember from
that everything else is kind of like a
blur
wow because i don't think
anybody could have
seen how special of a moment that would
have been in the future like you like
it's it's lived on it's on youtube like
no one knew youtube was gonna you know
you didn't know how that moment was
gonna be yeah but received 20 years down
the line right and not right you're
right 100 and also i feel like
no one in the room was kind of thinking
you know what let's come back and do
this 20 years later well let's let's do
this let's let's make it this 10 10 year
anniversary every 10 years we come back
to a round tables you know toray just
took took the percentage the royalty and
just ran off you know torrey didn't even
you know torrey i'm waiting on my call
man like let's let's do round table part
two let's
did he did he monetize that but look
that toray can you see him on cnn man i
see him on cnn yeah man you know that
came from somewhere right you know i'm
just messing with you already like it's
all love man i'm just saying to you that
in general though
no one turned it into like what i'm
trying to say is and rap
you know
everything else man they franchise
everything
rap
you know
we do it late and if we do it we we
don't allocate the funds properly
it's just it's crazy man we're the trend
setters but it's that's not what sets us
back what sets us back is how we
like how we allocate
and how we you know adjudicate
yeah i think that like we said earlier
right i think that finally there's a
generation of i think the newest
generation of of artists is finally
starting to become hip to that right you
know the fourth wall is kind of broken
down
you know there's a direct to consumer
connection with fans now that never
existed right that's true so where
imagine if in 1998 you had your
opportunity to
talk to your fans directly right address
them directly or say hey uh
swipe up on my story and buy
you know the new [ __ ]
cannabis hoodie or whatever you know
what i'm saying like it's it's just i
think now that the fourth wall is kind
of starting to be broken down like there
are
a lot of artists who are taking
advantage of the things that they try to
i guess maybe keep from the artists you
know because yeah
yeah but okay so when you i understand
exactly what you're saying and you know
i got a caveat to that
so
so yeah right get your record uploaded
to this site and they're gonna you know
go ahead and put this out depending on
what package you buy and so forth and so
on right yeah but then but then but then
you know then you got guys like like 80
who
you know can give you can make sure that
your records get uploaded to these sites
or whatever but they are still hand to
hand you know i visited them i went to
the warehouses today no i know i've seen
i've seen that many posters like there's
real physical copies but that's how it
has to be done it can't just be you
upload it to a site you got to have a
middle man that's going to a jedi that's
going to go out there and get these
things for you if you just upload it to
a site i'm here to tell you because i
get i get the
the quarterly
uh the court i get the quarterly it's a
it's a much it's a much higher or more
steep mountain decline to get your money
off the stream i'm assuming i'm gonna
show them i'm gonna give you the facts i
get the envelopes the quarterly
envelopes of the royalties and you know
you know zero point zero zero zero one
eight
is what you get on a play right
absolutely it's it's an eighth of a
penny yeah so now
you know so you get 10 million
two main plays right what is that like
six thousand dollars that's 38 000
that's 38 38 right that was fast hey
y'all this man's a savant
that was freaking fast i mean a million
on spotify is about
i liked no a millionaire was fast a
million on spotify is about 3 800
all right so i'm here to tell you man
like a million on spotify that means
that you're you're you are obscenely
popular right now right
moderately popular yeah but like 3 800
bucks hold on what does 3 800
do
for someone who is
that popular listen bro all you can do
is get into trouble with that all you
can do is go to the mall right
blow it on next week's outfit right
right and be broke or go go or pay your
rent for the month that's all you can
for one month that's all you can do so
now
all that
you know packages and
gulf streams flying here and that would
you're putting yourself in harm's way
just to catch up to what you've already
done you've already sold a million plays
so this is what i'm talking to you about
you know let's not let's not let's let's
call it what it is here man this is
already set up
you're already set up for failure
so
you know as opposed to focusing on the
beasts and you know the disc all these
things that can be worked out the
disagreements to you know you know i
mean musical styles who you know who's
living on this side of the world and
who's living here and there like as
opposed to focusing on all that there's
got to be some kind of a you know i'm
saying regulatory body and i'm talking
about even off paper like nothing that
you got to sign but just some kind of a
a lodge something that's put together
the brothers can come together i'm
talking from all walks of life and try
to have strategies that protect
us right i'm not trying to do that just
for anybody listening is thinking like
somebody i'm trying to yeah i'm not
trying to do it i don't want to be the
one to do it i wouldn't even take a job
and it's my candidate with something
like that but
someone out there that's listening that
has the wherewithal and the mental
faculty to handle the pressure of that
should take that on you know i'm i'm
gonna nominate you because that math
that mathematic maneuver that you just
did right now was so fast you don't see
it so fast man i'm so impressed with
that bro that's crazy i mean yeah
10 times 3 800 yeah
but yeah
um what year did you enlist in in in in
the uh you went to the army right yeah
one yeah oh one so that was uh was that
right after bc it so so 2000 bc came out
in 2000 yeah yeah so
you know kind of give give us like a how
was your experience man like like like
it's like co1 and this is september 11th
happens yeah it's a hell of a time
in the army it is right after september
11th so um
pretty much um
you know that experience i mean what can
i say man like i at that time i made a
record it was um
it was the uh the situation stories that
was the album the album was you know it
was satire i've heard people say yo it's
satire it's true it was it was it was
just done to kind of like
uh
uh
like allegorically like make an album
that was
uh
you know just get under the skin you
know what i mean folks that was saying
that yo man i need the records to be
hard i want you to spit harder the beach
the lyrics you know i want more and then
and then i gave him less
right by making a record like that and
the record was was strictly just
something that
it wasn't serious but it was like
something that it was it was it was
still palatable it was something that
was tangible you could have went out got
the artwork look at it open the fold out
right you know who's this guy wearing
that shirt yeah why is he writing that
and you know we paid 25 bands for the
source ad you know to run that
source and you know what the source was
scared to run the ad because of the
relationships that they were saying
could have been ruined right
and they did it for the money of course
they did you know that's what i'm trying
to say so and then after that they turn
around and blackboard me further you
know what i mean so and took money you
know what i mean to like blackball me
right so you know you're talking about
that record was made like the way i felt
at that juncture was like you know what
rapping it you know i'm still young
enough to go out and make a difference
and do something else yes right and and
and pretty much like
be a kaiju in a way for you know try to
do something good right but then of
course you know you make records and you
know you do a record like uh
and you do record like draft me and you
say a lot of crazy stuff on the record
and then you know you grow you get older
you see things you know other people see
things you you know you become
privileged certain things and you're
like man wow it's like you know
everywhere you turn you're trying to
make a difference trying to make a
change
and uh
you kind of find yourself like adding on
to
some of the things that have made the
world more disconnected right because
before and after pictures tell you a lot
about
you know what what
what how good
something was right before and after
pictures right yep so that's all really
you got to do man that's my answer how
many how many years were you in the
service i mean you know got in and over
four is supposed to be two right but got
into 04 got in no one and got out no
four so and then you had did you you
went overseas
uh no that's not you didn't you didn't
end up going overseas i didn't do that
okay okay
yeah it's just an interesting experience
you know because it's like
i remember seeing that in
whatever magazine like oh [ __ ] cannabis
is in the i mean you know i mean i did i
did write doctrine for the strikers bro
like first brigade to have them
um you know i always was like a
getaway driver kind of guy and um even
though i was a scout 19 delta
um
you know i i i was i was on the three
truck man striker brigade wrote wrote
doctrine help write doctrine for those
vehicles wow they performed and i did
they definitely used me to test them
test the performance so that's big yeah
no it it do you think that at that point
in time
mentally
you were just
this rap [ __ ] is enough because i feel
like the
you know the industry wasn't good to you
you know what i'm saying after that
first appreciate you even like you know
what i mean just just saying that man
you know i appreciate you even just
saying that man like
i'm not looking yo listen man i'm not a
bleeding heart myself so i don't really
you know listen man people have been
dealt worse hands right true true but
but the thing is just when you just look
at the potential of certain things right
some people it's gonna sting them harder
because of
what they were
you know
what they were
innocently
trying to
you know trying to increase or help or
assist
it's going to sting those folks harder
because it's like you come into
something
bright-eyed bushy-tailed you know
nobody's
innocent when they're 100 years old
right but when you're 20 you know you're
innocent of a lot of the things that
you wouldn't be at 40 or 50 right right
so at that age man
come on man i was innocent like in terms
of like what i was trying to bring to
the game with music you know and uh
yeah
i mean i can't say it though i can't say
that the industry wasn't good to me when
you said
you know i just say amen
and i applaud now just remember
specifically obviously at a certain
point in time it felt like you were like
the industry's
next guy everyone was behind you i mean
i remember seeing you you had you had
your source cover you were you were very
much uh
you know
i remember like the nas main source
moment you know what i mean like we
always did it it almost felt like that
was like the closest thing where it was
like yo live at the bar because it's
just kidding
and then you were kind of like the 96 97
version of that right
and
the first album comes out it's i i you
know i thought there was some [ __ ] on
there i like did like n word nominatory
and get [ __ ] i mean you know there's
some [ __ ] amazing records on there
but for whatever reason
it felt like you nowadays people get
more than one go i feel like people kind
of that album came and went and like
maybe the beef was like a even though
you won it right
it might have been a bigger curse than a
you know it was kind of a gift and a
curse hey man it's possible like i i
really i really will tell you that
you know
what
what i was up against i really didn't
know
at that time right and then by the time
i figured it out what i was up against
um
everyone had abandoned ship right i was
pretty much by myself right
um
and
it was something that
i realized what it was or what i thought
it was definitely a heavier pill to
swallow than
you know didn't
been being something simple to mitigate
something to figure out get out of right
but i was in the middle of it so i
couldn't quit i couldn't lay down and i
couldn't just sit there and wait for you
know that that that grindstone that
grinds everything to dust
you know what i mean so i had to keep it
pushing and that's what i did and
um that i'll give you know i give all of
or praise to the creator for me still
being here now because there were dark
times there i'm sure things that went
through and and you know
right now though
even though you know we talk about
you're the industry there's nothing yeah
but you know what though
like the kaiju the release of this kaiju
record there were records man like you
got melatonin magic you got like for
whom to be told you have a lyrical law
you had to rip the jacker like there
were records that michael the curriculum
there were a lot of records that came
out in time flies there were records
that came out after that
that
i'd say the brotherhood like the fan
base the listeners the rippers like
people that
they don't care what what the game
talking about what the industry talking
about they want to hear what candles got
to say yeah
they came through in the clutch right
and they stepped up to the plate in such
a way where
i mean if if that's all that there is or
that's all that you can walk away from
with it i gotta tell you that i'm more
than blessed
to have that or to have secured it
through that same innocence i'm older
now i'm not perfect right but
some of that innocence is still there
and
this brotherhood that i'm talking about
they have reflected that innocence and i
see it and when they come to support
they know that it was a lot they don't
know exactly what i was burying on my
shoulders but they know there was a lot
and now they kind of like they step to
the plate i mean these people they're
older now like all the rippers that were
following me back
in the 90s
they all got kids now man mostly all of
them they're all grown they all got you
know what i mean
they all
you know this pandemic for the last two
years man like they're still out here
getting it popping right like subsisting
you know like striving right and
then for them to set aside like you know
what i'm gonna get that new this album
whatever and then to be able to make it
number two across all the platforms it's
independent man we just went to the
warehouse we picked and people are
buying the physical copies they're yeah
so so i wanna i wanna i wanna i wanna
take take a snapshot of that and
highlight that because that is the
moment where i can like like look on
what happened you know with a with with
more of like a
you know i mean if if if if it wasn't
real and it was all fake then that mean
the rippers now that i got wouldn't have
existed but they're here god they're
here because obviously with your
yeah i do think like you know i think
back to life grateful for that is what
i'm saying and and and if you really
think about like i do think like the
big misconception is like your first
album wasn't fire right
i always thought it was great right and
obviously like you said you look at how
many years later right
there's still people who are putting
money in your pocket for a new album so
it obviously cut through to a certain
extent but like i i mean maybe it just
wasn't the industry success that people
had hoped it to be no i did 150 000
units for this week [ __ ] big you know
what i'm saying most people that keeps
the lights on most people would chop
their arm off
to do that that's just the first week
you know what i'm saying yeah first week
it was number two on billboard like it
was it was behind lauren
and you know he's right behind his
number two ireland lauren hill was
number one right yeah
that week so
who can be lauren nobody right so yeah
you know what i mean so and i remember
you know i remember being told like yo
it's a failure you know why somebody at
the label right
and then and then i remember that
person's equal on the other on the other
wing of the building came and said what
are you talking about like number two
this is your first release
you'll never be able to get it get
another first release again you'll have
other releases but you'll never be no
matter what you do you'll never be able
to first release again enjoy it for what
it is right your champion you know you
know you know enjoy it don't be sad
right because i was torn when when the
other one came to me and said oh it's a
failure so
you know what i mean so but but this and
i was young man like you gotta
understand like psychological
you know games and abuse on that level
you know what i mean in a in a game that
was already like you know everything's
big right like you know these these
owners and all that they had everything
you could ever think of right and we had
i mean walking in you have nothing right
you just want something you don't even
want what they got like when i say
innocent i mean innocent like
you know a lot of the guys i remember
meyer we weren't looking to have
everything that they had right we were
just looking to have something right and
to see that
that that kind of that that agreement
was made that okay if you do this this
and this
you'll have this and this and this or
you just have this and this or you just
have this right and if you open the door
she was behind door number one and knew
you'd have been like look man yeah let
me just break out right now go to
vocational school let me just get this
out the way right now right now
so
yeah i wanna i wanna highlight that man
like you know you gotta you gotta you
gotta definitely you gotta grow with
your your fan base and
you know what i mean and and sometimes
they're growing with you but when the
when the tables turn you got to grow
with them that's really good yeah um
give me the back story on how mike tyson
ended up on second round knockout oh man
you know what i'm saying like if you
want to talk about sucker my knockout
again
then we could easily focus on i don't
want to talk about the beef i just want
to talk about it
how did mike tyson end up on the second
round knockout no no i mean listen this
is mike second round knockout one more
time just say it i just went second
round knocking yeah right there
how did
yeah
mike
tyson
what you all want right so we're gonna
talk about i don't even want to talk
about the beef i just want to know mike
tyson getting on that record right how
did that happen i'm gonna tell you story
i'm gonna tell you i'm gonna tell you
i'm gonna tell you first i want you to
tell me
when's the last person you heard
somebody ask mike tyson about cannabis
i don't know i would though no but
nobody has i'm gonna tell you why she
punch you in your [ __ ] neck you
understand as i said i wouldn't ask him
yeah sure i would sure
i just don't think people are talking to
mike tyson
you know yeah they don't want to do that
right but the whole thing is this
at the time there were friends of mine
you know shout out to like you know i
don't even want to say his name because
i say his name is like i'm throwing his
name and and something that has so much
drama behind it but there was a there
was a friend of mine was working closely
with um both business-wise and just like
you know we we put projects out together
right and um
you know he was able to get in contact
with you know another close friend of
mike's uh female um you know and then
she had a son and that son you know i
don't want to say i don't want to say
people's names
because these people don't want to hear
about this [ __ ] you do you see what i'm
trying to say so i would say you know
they they wanted to uh
they wanted to work with me so
um they took it to mike
and when when the sun you know mike's
you know my sister his her son so his
nephew heard the record they heard my
name and it was me he was like oh man
you gotta listen to what else he's doing
and he would throw that up and mike was
like oh man that [ __ ] all right yeah so
it happened just like that it was there
was no
there was no animosity in it it was a
record that was made like more out of
like okay okay this hip-hop's getting
interesting now you understand what i
mean
and um there was innocence to it is what
i'm saying but just because it it was
like an air strike of sorts
it felt and and it was to the the big
empire you know what i'm saying that
basically ran rap
it turned into something where it's like
man you just woke up the great dinosaur
man like the you know the t-rex man and
and it turned into something else but
mike was just mike was with it just
because it sounded dope it was dope you
know what i'm saying were you in the
studio with him when he laid his
absolutely
you know what i mean what was that like
because i think of like the equivalent
would be like if lebron james jumped on
someone's disc record in 2021 because
mike tyson in 98 is
i mean arguably the most famous athlete
it's him in jordan you know what i mean
i was witness to it so what was that
what was that like being in the studio
with mike tyson okay so so so to add
clarity to him be fully transparent he
didn't come to the studio first and do
the record i was in the studio with him
several times but he didn't do this the
record in the studio that was done on a
on a dat recorder
you know at the time that type of dad
recorded that piece of queen's like two
bands man 2500 and it was he did his
part in the comfort of his own home we
were in vegas and his home next next
door was the sultan of brunei
you know funny story about that mike
took me over there you know i got to see
the sultan brunei's home and all that
wow you know yeah you know horse track
on the grounds you know pretty much went
around the whole grounds
um laser beam security at the time
of satellite laser
security at the time like just crazy
right and um tyson did the drops like in
the in the comfort of his own home
and and we we you know he he did he said
he said no one told him what to say
he just added that's what he said yeah
and then
took that
and you know chopped it up
and you know when the part in the
beginning when i'm when the door is
there and i go to the monastery you know
if you look at it man it was so i really
like
sly stallone you understand what i mean
and um
i built i i wrote the the treatment
for that song like out of like a rocky
kind of
the rocky vibe the vibe from all the
rockies with or even like the clint
eastwood vise where you know somebody
shows up
to the town
they wipe your family out they take
everything from you
you know they break they break your
strong hand you know you got to come
back and learn how to shoot with the
other one you know what i mean you gotta
you know you got to make a complete
comeback and then you ride back into
that town right right and that was by
that was what the second round knockout
record was it wasn't a first assault it
wasn't uh you know what i'm saying it
wasn't a
airstrike in the middle of the night it
was a response to something of course
people i think people forget that too it
was a response you get where i'm coming
from yeah it was a response and but but
you know what though we cleaned all that
up
we cleaned it all up and
i couldn't have made the cleanup any
bigger
if i could have i would have but i
couldn't make the cleanup any bigger
that's up to
other you know
other hands right other steady hands
right so you know here we are again man
we're talking about something that
was cleaned up but the cleanup wasn't as
big as the is the mess right
so the mess is still there that's why
you're asking me about it well no i'm
asking you about mike tyson it's the
same [ __ ] man no i think i just i just
think like to be able to to to to to
have experiences with 1998 mike tyson
yeah it's so crazy oh mike mike in 98
mike mike was firm-footed though right
he was from because he i think that
i think that he
i mean when i went to his home in vegas
man there was so many books on that
bookcase man and he's read every one of
them
and i think people now know this right
but at the time i don't think anyone
could have imagined that he was that
studious right but when you look back on
it it makes sense
it makes sense he was real strategic but
you know let's think about it man during
that time in 98 he had already gone
through some of this real madness you
know what i mean in his life and he
turned all that around you know what i
mean and now
people don't even really talk about that
madness no more they let him live no i
love mike i know but i'm saying they let
him live but me i'm still here i can't
live y'all y'all still want to talk
about the madness and i just don't
understand like what the [ __ ] is it man
i mean it's just hip-hop history man it
was hip-hop history but y'all but
everybody
has heard it already
they just haven't had me sit in front of
them and say it to them right but
they've heard it already i'm confused
man i'm so disappointed man
no i mean i think that you know for me
it's just more the angle of like so let
me ask you this
like i said it's like if lebron james
was on a record i would want to know how
the how did lebron you know you know
that's i'm not i'm not i agree with you
man i'm not even kicking the tires i'm
not on you you know what i'm saying i'm
not on you i'm just i'm just
it's i'm just i'm just uh i just kind of
like i get it yo i want to figure it out
i didn't want to figure it out before
you started talking about it to this
this but i do want after you start
talking about it like this
i'm i'm really it's like it's like a
ruby's cube it's a puzzle that i don't
know how it can be solved where it's
like
i mean you know what i mean can a [ __ ]
just live but um
but let me ask you this though
you heard the album the kaiju i haven't
listened to it yet oh yeah
what was the first record that came out
oh man that's all you heard you ain't
give a [ __ ] about candice man no that's
not true you do you listen to the record
i just got off of a 10-day vacation with
my wife for our anniversary i just got
back sunday from putin i got records you
could have played at punta cana and
tulum and you probably wouldn't want to
go to town i was sitting on the beach
with the wife for our anniversary i just
got back
monday night true choo choo i feel you
so
it's not that i don't want to listen to
where i'm going to i just literally you
know i haven't haven't gotten around to
it so it's records on there there's
records on kaiju that
some dope features
yeah yeah yeah i got dodged i got a
dmx just as ad-libs you know for those
out there who think i'm trying to i'm
not trying to
tell people to go grab it because x is
on there but that was my way of paying
homage to him and my relationship with
him and my connection to him you know
what i mean because
i never had any way of of of making that
possible without without those ad-libs
right right and um you know i think
think uh thank you you know what i'm
saying like
you know extraordinaire for that right
making those connections but uh
yeah you know there are records on kaiju
that i would say are you know vastly
more important than
anything that happened in 98
but you know until you hear you won't
know but then for those out there who
have heard it they could probably agree
they could come on and point out to you
maybe five six or seven things inside of
records just vastly more important than
happen in 98. do you feel like with
kaiju because what i'm noticing is like
with the horseman release and the and
kaiju like
york
it feels like
you're really taking advantage of the
fact that you know what you do have a a
a core fan base that will break bread
with whatever cannabis does and i think
that sometimes
people forget that right like you know
like when you put it out like you said
earlier right like you're not just going
straight to streaming platforms you're
pressing up records you're
you know you you have you're
you're
essentially
giving something tangible to fans still
when that's not a thing and i think that
you know shout out to uh the griselda
guys have done a good job of doing it in
the last few years but i feel like i it
was dope to see
you know with the last couple releases
that was kind of something on the
forefront of like the business model of
of what the kaiju record is it's like
hey look man i'm still here and
let's make sure that not only can you go
stream it but you can also
hold it well to be honest to be
absolutely honest because it's all
grassroots there's really no promo money
going and there's nobody offering up any
assistance with that you know it's just
this team small team too you can count
them on you can count them on one hand
and if we if need be you can count them
on two hands but that's it
and i gotta tell you that
we're we're not always absolutely sure
that
you know there's gonna be any support
for records i mean if you go on google
right now you type in cannabis kaiju
it's not going to just come up bro the
site that was built to support the
record will come up but it's not coming
up nowhere else you understand what i'm
trying to say so
let's not let's not take the narrative
and throw it somewhere else act like oh
yeah canada's got a solid fan base and
all that like no
i got folks that you know by the grace
of the creator right are able to you
know
you know stand on their own in their own
lives and they just happen to you know
little birdie says hey man [ __ ] just
dropped the album and then they say to
themselves you know what
i'm kind of going through right now let
me see what bitch's going through
because i always listen to bits when i
want to go work out when i want to get
motivated when i want to get inspired to
like go out here and deal with life and
try to you know what i mean try to win
try to get a victory out of you know
something that's really really you know
hampering me right now that's that's
where i think it comes from it's just
people saying let me give this a shot to
listen to it so the pressure's still on
me to make a record that's going to
give them that extra yo let me do two
more sets you know what i mean let me do
you know what i mean so that's what it
is we're never like
we're never going into it thinking it
we're gonna
certainly get this amount or do this
amount because at the end of the day if
you see the numbers or whatever they're
still small bro
it's it's nothing compared to you know
like
you know a shout out from a mega mogul
that you know that's that's out here
yeah but listen i mean i would say this
though but like what you can do
is with a lot of people who might listen
we talked about a million streams right
right right it's 3 800 yeah i haven't
done a million streams no no but but but
but what you can do is something that a
lot of these kids can't do and that's
sell this
and
you know sell the pre-order with them
but let's put it in perspective but
let's put it in perspective like they
can sell this and they can do a million
streams and so forth and so on but they
don't have somebody asking them about
second round knockout and trying to
constantly box them in see what i'm
saying like i would trade a clean slate
for what you're what you're praising me
for right now
i trade it for queens like that's how
crazy all that [ __ ] was but nobody
understands that you see what i'm saying
everybody comes and acts like oh you got
so much you can do so much but i'm
shackled to that [ __ ]
do you feel like that that you're [ __ ]
you you do you feel like that's like
obviously look at the end of the day
if
you know
if you've made hip-hop history you've
been a part of hip-hop history right and
you're also someone who's kind of
not
accessible
not very you know like i said you kind
of get in and get approachable not
really accessible right right okay so
you know i think it's you have to kind
of expect
we're sitting here for two hours right
i'm gonna bring it up it's it's it's a
highlight of you know yeah that's that
you know what that's if
that's if you don't really know the
whole catalog bro like if you knew the
whole catalog like so i got like
3
500 or some songs registered right
registered which is
like sounds you know how much that is
because you did the math that fast
right right so
that's that's that's it so so let's
let's take let's take you might have
more registered songs than any rapper
ever maybe
but and i probably would like right
after we get off but now so in my mind
right and in the mind of the people who
know me best
that one song that everybody keep
talking about if we just subtract that
one song from the catalogue there's
still thirty
three seven you understand where i'm
coming from i get it so that's exactly
where we stand i understand how that
could be frustrating it's not
frustrating to me i'm almost i'm almost
looking at the rap community like
they're slow
and this is why we're in the [ __ ] that
we're in right and that's why i've
stopped
trying to
augment the direction that that's that's
going to get us because they're not just
doing it with me they're doing all the
artists out here
they're taking narratives that will
shackle people to things
that that
muck up the gears
and make it so that they can't you know
make an impact
of value
they make it they turn it into something
that the only value that can come from
it is like you know the ops right
what what they're selling
and how they're changing the narrative
and how you know maybe something
unfortunate can happen to the
you know to the to the to the the light
you know what i mean or just the
balancer or the equalizer they want
something to happen to the equalizer man
well listen the way i look at it is this
right
i think that that situation is
historical to in the same way that i
think that that roundtable that udmx pun
and mike geromino was historical so
as a hip-hop fan as someone who
participated as a consumer in that era
like you know personally that's
something i wanted you know i want to
ask you about that day when you were
sitting at that table in the same way i
want to you know ask you about
i specifically remember right
participating as a as a fan in that
situation so beautiful man and and
yet again i can stand here on this side
of the fence and say okay so let's look
at the round table like
what happened to everybody on the panel
like including me man
like or any of the potentially everybody
who was on that panel potentially
did any of us even get to like
half our real potential
i think really it was just x right
you're saying x got to half of its
potential i think it got fully too bad i
think i mean at the end of the day dmx
had what five or six number one albums
in a row oh so you're talking about
materialism then now five five and so
you come on materialism no i just mean
in terms of
of commercial
success so that's his potential was
commercial success no i mean what are we
talking about i mean because i said
potentially
they reached half their potential like
what do you think that anybody on that
panel reached half of their potential
just that's what you think too
i don't think he reached half his
potential like like you're talking about
records and sales of money right but
even when he passed
there were issues like surrounding like
what money is going where and what i
agree that yeah
i don't i don't agree because it depends
on what what scope are we looking at
through when you ask that one school
it's one scope it's only one scope
everybody's sitting at that table right
okay
did they reach half their potential
because i feel like if
any of us at that table had reached half
a potential it would be like obscenely
visible now
and not just financially
you get what i'm trying to do i
understand what you're saying yeah and
so and so and so that's why i
will always push back with that kind of
conversation people come with that [ __ ]
i just look at it like damn man hip hop
is slow look man i'm gonna push back
like i always would saying that
you know
it's like we're hunted bro
it's like we're hunted man
you know what i'm saying and
somebody somewhere is not satisfied
until everybody on the panel
it's like
it's like some kind of a [ __ ] up
horror film man you know what i'm saying
or novel
that's the way i look at it and that's
where a lot of people that listen to my
music look at things man because you
know what unfortunately it looks like
that's the way it is everybody else is
slow to catch up man everybody else
thinks it is just about this material
stuff or you know you did reach all this
potential because your name is
everywhere but you know what are you
miserable
is your family miserable you know what i
mean are you is certain things going
through certain hardships where you got
to look at it and be like damn
considering all of the people
that would look up to x and say you got
me out of some real rough times brother
and i love you for it and i always
support you for it you know sometimes i
people tell me that definitely not as
much times as x has heard that right and
so
you know yeah i mean i think i i i just
get sad bro i get sad when people try to
act like
what they've done
like what like what what the game is
you know
giving back to
us
is is satisfactory man i push back bro i
disagree i mean listen i told you in
general i mean i think in general the
industry has has has
you know was was rough to towards you
okay well you're telling me this [ __ ]
stinks i'm telling you though that that
what
what happened
the reason behind what happened i'm
pointing in the direction at it i can't
isolate what it is because i can't
breathe air that far up in the clouds
but you know because it's rarefied up
there but
trust me when i tell you man like
the fans really do
you know if it's not if it wasn't for
them
like you know some of the things that
you see like you look at that panel
dudes wouldn't even have been able to
get what they got like now
you know what i'm saying and that that's
the part that that's the point i push
back on is somebody's coming to try to
say oh yeah well you guys
because you're not the only one boss
it's not it's not your fault you're not
at fault here you just and then here i
am like just giving you like yeah look
at the panel you talk about the panel
like look
so
how you think i feel like being that i
was on the panel
i feel like
a small part of me is feeling like i'm
carrying a flag for that right
and then another part of me is like
you'll stay away from that [ __ ] you
understand what i'm trying to say but
you
want to know because you think the fans
want to know so you dragged me into that
you get where i'm coming from
i think the fans would want to know
about that day fans don't give a [ __ ]
about that man that [ __ ] has been on
youtube yeah but but it's not it's not
about it's not about that video it's
about like yo what's the like yo tell me
about that night you know what i'm
saying like i think people yeah i don't
even remember that [ __ ] night like if
you want to keep it all the way a buck
that [ __ ] there's so much [ __ ] that's
happened in my life like like that [ __ ]
is like it's just another totally get it
but at the same time like
i wasn't even like i said what would i
say when you brought that up i brought
up you said i remember there was love no
yeah i did say that yeah but i also said
that toray
you know he did the sign-offs and there
was no percentage kickbacks if i'd have
got a percentage kickback on that
i probably remember it a whole lot
better that's real you see what i'm
trying to say so let's let's let's be
you know what i mean let's be let's be
pragmatic about what we're talking about
here man because i don't even like doing
interviews because every the the
narrative they always grab the net and
it's always somebody just slower than me
you know what i'm saying it grabs the
narrative and takes it and goes
somewhere else with it and then i end up
in the middle and i end up being a bad
guy when all i'm trying to do
is
just like the kaiju record i'm trying to
i'm trying to keep something afloat here
while i'm trying to assist or help you
know what i'm trying to say right
it's always been like that and it just
seemed like rap you know what it seems
like to me man yeah and i'm gonna say
this one shut up about it yeah it seems
like rap is the death
of us
rap is the death of us bro
you know what something say like the
artists that come out and they make
their music
and they're impactful
and they're you know there's some good
in them and they're out there and
they're making a difference for the
better
rap is the death of them
not something else but rap
[Music]
i mean also literally and and
figuratively as well because i mean
we've seen that's what i mean yeah
that's what i'm saying and that's a
goddamn shame
that's all i'm saying man well listen
man the new album but let's not be sad
about anything right well you got a new
album out the horsemen album is out you
got a lot of you know there's there's
listen you've had a great 2021 as far as
output what is uh you know
is this are you going to take a break or
is this like with this new energy of
this new record are you kind of do you
kind of have the bugs that you know you
say new energy yeah i feel you i really
feel what you're trying to do man you
know what i'm saying is i feel you like
you've had a crazy year of output like
come on man look i feel what you're
trying to say i really what i'm asking
is like when like are you gonna it's not
it's working are you gonna keep staying
in the studio it all depends man well
the creator makes that decision not me
like the big g god makes that decision
not me and we've seen that right with
with so many other things so many other
people and
people that we love artists we love
right we don't make i don't make that
decision anyway but
the 2021
there were some bright moments in it
right
but on kaiju so i did a record called
coveted santa right
when you
listen to the record you'll hear covet
santa kovacen is a real snapshot to me
of what things are really like that's
that's the snapshot of what things were
that's 2021 to me listen to that record
if you listen to that record
yeah you know i mean covet santa that
pretty much sums it up right yeah i mean
you know yeah but
that to me is a snapshot of where things
are at right so
you know
all i can say now is like hey we still
in the trenches right um
you know we take it day by day
you know everybody out here pounding
pavement to do the best that we can and
then sometimes you know we know that
something ain't working or whatever we
keep it pushing and we leave it alone
you know what i mean this is not some
kind of resurgence to canvas or nothing
like that man i'm still the same dude
you're just going to do what makes sense
if it makes sense you're going to do it
if you're feeling you're going to do it
and yeah yeah yeah
it's all good because you're still the
same guy either way that's what it is
hey so what what's the website that
everyone can go and like if they want to
actually physically
buy the music i appreciate that you know
uh so if you want to um
just be involved you know
hang out with with uh with people who
like cannabis music they bump that you
know i got i got bourne sun with me i
got uh you know um you know the team my
rippers um pretty much like
everybody you can imagine it's like
messing with real hip hop i've got body
bag been on this album uh we're forging
new relationships you know uh 80s
reaching out to new people forcing new
relationships right and then some of the
old relationships if they're if they're
reputable we can't we're repairing right
if they if they're being our approach we
leave them alone but um
you know
kennynft.com that's
c-a-n-i-n-f-t dot-com you can go there
to like directly support get involved
yeah and just and get involved with what
what i'm up to next right um you got
ipictorial.com that's like the future
right that's what you were talking about
earlier yeah that's the future and so
for anybody that wants to like put the
goggles on right just like he was
talking about kid cootie
like what would you say kid cootie he
had her cut it kick kick cut it good
come on
yeah so kid cudi right so he had like
something where they performed yeah
[ __ ] right now when we know that's a
huge artist right brings a lot a whole
lot of fanfare and everything look you
can put the goggles on to go see him
right well you can put the goggles on
and see me too but you got to go to
aperture.com there it is man i
appreciate your time man real [ __ ]
brother i appreciate